All right, now that we have our player controller set up we're doing our line trace
What we're gonna do now is we are going to go to our
Activatable actor blueprint and create a new child blueprint of this and we're gonna set it up to work as our light
So let's just pop over here to the editor
control space to bring up our content browser and again, we want to create a child blueprint of our
Activatable so there's our BP activatable. So we're gonna right-click on this create child blueprint class and we are going to call this
BP light
All right. So let's double click on that to open it up
bring this on screen and
We're gonna come over here to our components and we are going to add a new component and we're gonna add a point light
There we go. And we do want to make sure that our point light is set to movable, which it is
There we go
just make sure that that is set to movable and then what we're gonna do is we're gonna come over to our event graph and
inside of our event graph we're going to
Click in here and we're gonna look for
event
activate and we want this event activate object and what this is is this is
looking for our BPI activate interface and from
this we're gonna grab our point light here and we're gonna left click and drag and
If we just again left click and drag off of that and look for our
toggle we can grab this toggle visibility and
We can connect like so so what this is going to do is this is going to set up our
Point light so that it can be turned on and turned off. So let's just compile and save that and
Next what we're gonna do. We're gonna do something very very very similar
We're gonna create a child blueprint of our usable actor
We're gonna add a cube to that
and we want to make sure that this cube static mesh has some type of collision and then we're also going to be creating a
Variable that we can actually select inside of the level and use that variable to target our light
Switch so let's go ahead and come back over here. We're gonna hit ctrl space and again this time
We're gonna go to our BP usable actor right click
Create a child blueprint and we're gonna call this BP light switch
And then we're gonna double click on this to open it up now first things first
We're gonna come to our add and we're gonna look for this cube and we want to add the cube
I'm gonna leave it at this size this this large size
If you wanted to you could come here to the scale and change it make it a little bit smaller
But we don't need to do that
the next thing that we need to do is we need to come over here to our
variables and we're gonna add a new variable and we're gonna call this new variable light and
If we come over here to our variable type, we're gonna look for our BP underscore and we want this
BP activatable we want an object reference to this
Now we're not quite done with this yet
The next thing that we need to do here is we need to come down to our variables and we need to enable this
Public option. So what this does is this allows us to select different lights
once this has been placed inside of a level, so we'll go ahead and compile and save and
we're not quite done yet because the next thing that we need to do here is
We need to set up some of it graph logic so that we can actually select the light
Check to make sure that it is valid and then call our functions to turn it on and turn it off and
We do that by coming over here. I'm gonna come to our event graph. And again, we're gonna look for our
Event use and there's our event use object from our BPI usable and then we're gonna grab our light
Variable here and we're gonna get its current value
And then I'm just gonna left click and drag off of this from BPI usable and we're gonna look for is valid
And we want this is valid with a question mark right there. So is valid
What object do we want to make sure is valid? Well, we want to make sure that this light is valid
We want to make sure that there's something in there
and
Then what do we want to do if it is valid?
Well, if it is valid what we want to do here is we want to do an activate object
There we go
Activate object. There we go. That's what we want. We want our activate object target is BPI
Activate we also need to give this a target
So it needs to know what we want to operate on
So we're just gonna go like this and then we're gonna plug it this in like so and just like that
There we go
Just move this over make it a little bit easier to see. So there we go
all right, so let's go ahead and compile and save that and
the reason we were doing all of this is so that when again we're gonna
Put our light switch in but our light that we see right here
The ability to select that is directly related to us coming in here and setting this light to public
So let's go ahead and set this up by I'm gonna hit ctrl space ctrl space. We're gonna grab our light switch
So there's our light switch
All right, and then I'm gonna grab our light. There's our light which is right next to it
So there we go, and then if we select our light switch and we come over to our
Looks like I don't have a details panel
So we're gonna fix that by coming up here to window go details detail panel one. And there we go
I'm just gonna bring this over here on my screen. You can see here underneath our default
We have this light. So if I grab this eyedropper, I can select the light
Let's go ahead and hit play and what should happen now is when I press E
Let me get close to it. There we go
It turns it on and turns it off turns it on turns it off
look at that and
the other cool thing is that if we were to come here and I'm gonna hold down alt and select this one and
Grab this one right here and hold down alt we can have this select different ones
So check this out. This is kind of cool
so
That turns that one off that one turns that one off or if we wanted to we could even have these two
Select the same one so we could have like this one
Whoops, there we go. So you can see here we turn this one off and then turn it back on over here
So that's pretty cool. And again, here's what we get. We get our light on and our light off